It's important to note that although some people experience negative
consequences for using LSD or similar drug. Some researchers have found that
these drugs actually are really beneficial medications for some conditions. In
fact, this has led some of the top researchers in the field to examine the
beneficial therapeutic effects of these drugs.
&gt;&gt; That's right. For example, LSD has been used in the treatment of cluster
headaches and there's new research looking at LSD for treating drug dependence.
However, it's important to note that LSD is a schedule one drug, which means
there are serious consequences for both use and possession.
&gt;&gt; But who better to tell us about all this than two world-renowned experts in
their field. First, we're going to talk to Doctor Griffiths about his research
with psilocybin. Right, and then we'll come back and talk to Doctor Doblin, who
is the founder of the Multidisciplinary Association for Psychedelic Science.
He's going to discuss MDMA or Ecstasy with us.